welcome to all of you to have a very
interesting discussion this evening
that's important to us for a number of
reasons and one of those I like to point
out on such occasions old college is a
Christian college it is
nondenominational but by its articles
Association its original article
sociation it is to uphold in its
teaching the precepts and traditions of
the Christian faith so these questions
of religious liberty and persecution are
very important to us that they're
important to us because ills of college
also is very dedicated to teaching about
the American experiment in
self-government and we celebrate its
protections of religious liberty in the
First Amendment one of my great teachers
who was a Jew always loved to quote to
me and bring to class and and point out
when area the opportunity that the first
letter ever written by the head of state
officially to a Jewish congregation was
from George Washington who pointed out
to a group of Jews in a Hebrew
Congregation in Newport Rhode Island
that no longer is persecution the the
the model here but the rights that all
have by their nature to practice their
religious liberty but unfortunately that
understanding as much as we celebrate it
is not the way it works in most of the
world and we take too much for granted
sometimes hence our topic this evening
Lumbee induce our three speakers
beginning with Rachel Reynolds who is a
graduate of Hillsdale College where she
and earned her bachelor's degree in art
she also studied photography as you can
tell from the photos here at Florence
University of art in Florence Italy and
she was took a part in the few
leadership Institute's summer Prague for
in 2018 and she traveled to Israel and
Jordan and learned something about what
it was like to be a Christian in the
Middle East and the result of that these
photographs and her terror and hope
Christians of the Middle East which
we've made available to all of you
outside is the result of that and she's
going to tell us about that journey and
her experience then we're joined by
Julianne tomorrow Z yes sir thank you I
just let me try that right so the senior
fellow at the feuless project and
founder president of the Iraqi Christian
relief Council hopefully she'll tell a
little bit about her own story she was
smuggled out of Iran 1989 to avoid
religious persecution and she came to
America as refugee and eventually earned
her master's degree from Northeastern
Illinois University and she now does a
lot of TV and writing to promote the
cause of and provide aid to the Assyrian
Christians throughout the world she's
also the president of the Iraqi
Christian relief counseling I mentioned
that and then lastly a dear friend of
mine
Nina Shay is the director of Center for
religious freedom the Hudson Institute
this is a topic she is written about and
thought about and worked on for a long
time she's graduated Smith College in
American University of Washington
American years.he Washington College of
Law and she who has been appointed by
the US House of Representatives to the
Commission as commissioner of the u.s.
Commission on International Religious
Freedom seven terms so this is something
she knows quite about she's authored
several books including silenced how
apostasy and blasphemy codes are choking
freedom worldwide and most recently
persecuted the global assault on
Christians so this is a fabulous group
of individuals who can speak to this
very directly and I first especially
welcome Rachel here to speak to us this
evening hi thank you all for coming I
just first want to thank the college as
an alumna of a school that supported so
long I have such earnest ways I really
am grateful for being here I'd like to
share with you first my faith journey
and coming into advocacy work coming
into Hillsdale I was an atheist I knew
nothing about religion I'm sitting in
dr. Brad burgers classes and the
softball team Bible study was how I came
to faith so Hillsdale played a super
integral part in that journey I'm three
years ago I got an email as a student at
Hillsdale to go on a trip with 40 of my
peers to Israel and we spent 10 days
with passages Israel exploring the Holy
Land and it was my really first
experience understanding that there's a
culture outside the United States which
I think far too many people fail to
realize and I don't know if I hadn't
have gone on that trip that I ever
really would have solidified my views on
the topic since that trip I returned to
the Middle East as a fellow and
photographer for passages Israel and
it's kind of an introductory experience
where you kind of graze the areas so
that we're going to talk about tonight
so that was a very first stepping stone
last spring I found out I was chosen out
of a huge pool of applicants to go on
the exclusive felis Leadership Institute
I was kind of a out of the grain
applicant being an art major and I took
a shot at it and got in so very grateful
for that
and they took a chance on me as an
artist I spent two weeks diving deep
into these issues as they stand today
looking back at that history so the
people that I've met in many situations
on that trip that was daunting to me I
was able to visit refugee camp where I
saw how the Syrians coming out of the
civil war experiencing their life and
how it's affected them
we spent a night under the stars in the
Negev and we had dinner with a Bedouin
family but the most impactful experience
on that trip was sitting and listening
to these Iraqi Christians talk about
their stories and how they were
persecuted by Isis and ultimately
fleeing their homes they aren't given
refugee status by the UN which in
consequence
does not allow them to have work permits
or obtain healthcare as they are not
able to raise their own money we had
just come from Israel where thousands of
Christians leave peacefully and are not
inhibited from practicing those basic
human rights so I saw a hard line and
that hard line was a Jordanian border
into the rest of the Middle East and
while the people in Israel are able to
practice freely I just didn't understand
why a hundred and fifty miles could make
such a drastic difference and the
quality of life for those people so last
spring when I was on this journey of
finding out that I was going on the trip
I thought about how I as an artist can
contribute to this cause past
experiences with passages I really had
seen the issue felt empathetic but what
could I as someone who was freshly out
of college moving across the country for
a teaching job what could I do to impact
them and I knew that I had to use my
photography that was something that was
so close to me and I knew that impacted
people in different ways so as we sit
and listen to these people I tell their
stories I felt a plan just rushed over
me I couldn't tell exactly what that
meant but I knew that I had to take
captivating portraits of these people
one of the best pieces of advice I
received while I was at Hillsdale was
from professor Barbara bushy she told me
that I as a human made in the image of
God have a responsibility to create and
that is something that until a few
months ago and I shot her a text and
told her that how much that impacted me
I didn't realize that that is something
that I can leave a legacy and so it is
in His image this is what this causes
for and that's my responsibility so what
better way to advocate for these
persecuted people then use them as a
gateway into the souls and tribulations
of these people that are pictured I had
to somehow use that god-given creative
ability so moving forward I sat in this
incredibly hot room and at the front we
had each of the families come in with a
translator in Julianna
and I leaned into her and said hey can I
take these people into another room and
take portraits of them now keep in mind
these people didn't speak English I know
for Arabic words so how was I going to
get them to break down their walls right
and that was something that came to me
with no problem i sat and communicated
with these people how I've never
communicated with another human being
and it was holding their hands and
looking to their eyes and really just
watching those walls tumble and spill
out onto those images
baraz to who you've seen out in the
reception area she held my hand and she
saw him pleading for help with her two
siblings that she's unable to help
financially or she saw her light up as
she spoke with her church choir and I
saw that hope and that really kind of
triggered this hope initiative
mehran he is pictured on this side here
he was excited that someone just wanted
to come and help and he actually asked
if we could take a picture together
which inevitably made me sit there and
saw calm I was so broken he barely
looked at me he could barely look at me
without breaking down so me as someone
who grew up in Southeast Michigan and
that's not something outside of Flint
that I really saw right that's something
totally new the last people that really
made an impact was that a family of a
three year old named Berta she had been
diagnosed with leukemia I had a
childhood friend who also had the same
diagnosis but they now had they had fled
from Isis they were watching their
daughter die and there was not a thing
that father could do about it and how
could I sit there as someone who
attended some place like Hillsdale
College I'm a privileged white person in
America how could I not help that that's
just something that I couldn't settle
with so I took photographs of each of
these people I probably took five of
each of the people that came into the
room and when Berta's father and her
sister were sitting there and heard it
was too ill to travel
I took the father yep so this is the
father and her little
stur I saw the fear in his eyes and you
know just the ultimate sadness and hers
how am I gonna save my kid and that's
not that's not a problem that any parent
should face but especially when there is
literally no resources to reach out to
oh so before we even boarded the plane
back to the US I had these stories
written down I worked with Julianne and
other people on the trip to get these
stories into English into a paragraph
summarizing what we had heard we put
together this narrative through photos
and words of what's going on over there
so today that project is called terror
and hope persons of the Middle East we
published a book and thanks to the Kirby
Center they're all available to you to
pick up outside they're also available
on Amazon and all the prints are for
sale a most special about that is that
all of the funds from this is going
directly towards Burdick Berta's care
and anything in excess of that is going
to help pave the rent and the medical
expenses of all these people in these
photos so the Iraqi Christians are not
given the media coverage that other
persecuted peoples are given my hope is
that this inspires a conversation
it educates people that we can have an
open conversation about why Western
Christians are turning a blind eye and
we need to protect our brothers and
sisters in the Middle East Western
Christians are citizens of the world's
largest and strongest nations so so many
are helping worthy causes all around the
world why are we not gearing our efforts
towards those who are at the very roots
of what our country was founded on it's
time to just embrace those shared
histories and beliefs and not shy away
from the stories that exist because we
have the power to affect change for
these people so I'm here tonight so hope
that you all join me in that fight
Thanks
[Applause]
as as Rachel stalks my heart literally
is pounding in my chest because I am the
granddaughter of genocide survivor
I am the granddaughter of a genocide
victim of the armenian assyrian and
greek genocide of 1914 through 1923 I
escaped harassment myself I was blessed
to be able to do that but one and a half
million Christians of Iraq were unable
to on not all were able to do to say the
same thing as I am able to say today I
if I lived as a displaced person in Iran
because we were trying to find a
smuggler to smuggle me out I was taken
out of school for two years finally one
of the smugglers came and said I will
marry her I will convert her to Islam I
will destroy her Christian paperwork and
I will deliver her to her brother and my
brother at the time was living in
Germany and if I don't want to divorce
her I will not divorce her because she's
15 and she would be my bride the second
set of smugglers said we will dress her
in literal literally sheep clothing that
put her next to a real Sheep ship her to
India and from India will fly her to
Germany and deliver her to her brother
there were women who had taken that road
and they were never heard from again
the third smuggler after much prayer
much fasting came and created a fake
visa a fake passport into Switzerland my
mother and I stayed and hiding in
Switzerland at a monastery and then was
we were taken to Germany where we sought
religious asylum became refugees and
came to the States in 1990 somebody
asked me today how many hours a week do
you spend on this cause and I said how
many hours do you spend working I said
this is not work for me
this is breathing as though you would
ask how many hours of a day you breathe
truly I do this work for the greater
glory of God for to honor as
eight family members that were killed in
the hands of extremists of my own family
members and I do this to keeps a
Christian the cradle of Christianity
strong in the Middle East the Christians
of Iraq ethnically are Assyrians you
many of you have heard of the Assyrian
Empire from the Old Testament those who
have converted to Catholicism or
Chaldean called Kali and many of you
have heard of the Chaldean people Syriac
people and we've converted to
Christianity for 2,000 years we became
Christians through Saint Thomas the
Apostle so the Assyrians the Chaldeans
and Siri acts of Iraq although they have
been victimized for 2,000 years under
different regimes under different faith
groups that came through especially
Islam but they're resilient people
so one message I'd like for you to take
away with you is not just to look at
this peoples group as victims but
they're resilient people and that is the
term that we I want you to take with you
but I need you your hearts to break for
these people because they are the point
of death
we are refusing to renounce Christ out
of one and a half million Iraqi
Christians today we have barely two
hundred thousand left the rest of them
have fled many have been killed there 60
Assyrian Chaldeans Syriac women that are
still in the hands of Isis today and
this is unfolding in front of our eyes
my friends the news vibrates has
vibrated since 2003 since the invasion
or liberation of Iraq however you want
to look at that in our back pockets and
we've turned a blind eye to this so when
you speak and I'm so grateful to
Hillsdale and Kirby Center for opening
the door and I'm so grateful to every
one of you that have come here that have
taken the time to listen to the plight
of these people and you are going to do
I know you will do something about this
it is through your prayer it is through
your financial sacrifice it is through
your spreading the word and educating
others about their plight I'm grateful
because you're honoring my great
grandmother that was killed by the
curve's
her sister that was beheaded
Hertz it was her sister other sister
that was sold in sex slavery so this
this atrocity touches real-life people
there are not just numbers on the other
side of the world
so in specific we have 17,000 Iraqi
Christians that are living in Jordan we
have 25,000 living in Turkey we have
about four or five thousand in Lebanon
as you said this does not make the news
the refuge the UNHCR does not give
refugee status to these persecuted
people it refuses to it continuously
says to them you're on your there's a
backlog there's a backlog everything is
going to the Syrian Muslims everything
we went to the Zaatari camp I've been to
SATA recounts six times and we were when
we walked through the SATA account we
see the banners of these Christian
organizations that give umpteen amount
of money to their Syrian refugees the
Syrian Muslim refugees and then we go to
the Christians that have nothing there
have been multiple cases that they're
physical physically they've had they had
to be amputated because they didn't have
money for simple diseases like although
critical but simple diseases like
diabetes like heart disease blood
pressure it doesn't cost that much money
for us in America to help these people
to at least live with dignity
these 17,000 people we've been to Jordan
so many times we've met hundreds of
families the cost of living is high for
them because they're unable to work they
don't have the permit to work the
government of Jordan although were
grateful to them that they've given them
housing or they've given him shelter
rather they're not helping them UN does
not give them one penny Caritas gives
very little it actually was providing
education but as of 2018-2019 Caritas
when we were there has
fuse to give funding for school so if we
can make that change my sister here you
have a loud voice please let's let's
let's do something about that really
but the caught for example I'll tell you
it costs two hundred fifty dollars for
rent for these people to at least have
peace of mind
two hundred fifty dollars for us in
America may not be that much but it
makes a difference in these people's
lives when we were there one of the
women who has four kids we asked her
where is your bed she was sleeping on
the floor she said I sold my bed for
twenty five Jordanian dollars which is
about thirty to thirty three dollars
just so I can hold my justice in good
faith to show my landlord I'm trying to
raise the money for you we came back to
the states I was here at the ministerial
in June and July
she called me frantically crying saying
I'm behind two months can you please
help me the landlord is here so we we
spoke to the landlord we said we're
coming back to Jordan we're gonna bring
three months worth a friend for this
family just let her stay let her kids
stay her child had not eaten she was six
months old she had not she didn't have
baby milk for two nights she slept
hungry these are not just a number of my
friends the cost of living per family of
four to five six people is about seven
hundred it's about a thousand dollars
with medicine with food with electricity
with water bill and these homes are not
great homes many of them are roach
infested there are in terrible terrible
conditions Berta we talked about Berta
Berta has an incurable disease and she
was as Rachel said she was unable to
come at that very hot day in that very
hot room so her father and Cristina her
sister came and her father kept on
saying Cristina cries every day saying
will I be able to see my sister baby
sister girl grow up her medicine is
about five hundred dollars a month and
the proceeds from the books thank you so
much I'm so grateful we'll go to Berta
to give some relief to
father these people my friends when they
escaped Iraq it was at the moment's
notice when Isis came many on many
occasions church bells rang to let them
know that Isis the enemy is coming they
had homes they had jobs they had
businesses there was a man we met in
Iraq who had eight farms he was living
in a shipping container when myself a
fellows went in 2016 February he was
crying a grown man was crying much like
Kamal is Kamal somewhere was come on he
was crying he was saying I was a CFO I
was an assistant to the CEO of it this
insurance company in the Gulf countries
and look I have nothing I have two adult
handicapped kids how am I going to and
he was old and he privately said to me
I'm probably going to die at someone's
doorstep after all these years of
working I have nothing left every one of
you are able to make a difference when
my mother escaped the Bolsheviks because
my gray my grandfather escaped on foot
to Russia from northern Iran in 1914
when he was 12 years old he was taken
into a gulag camp 20 plus years later
his wife and child my mother were
shipped to Iran because he still had the
Iranian citizenship there was an
American priest that picked her out of a
line of that school paid her for her
education from her
I teach was seven or eight years old
until high school she interned instilled
the love of education and service in the
hearts and minds of her children and
that priest 80 years ago my mother's 87
80 years ago because of his goodness he
empowered me to do what I do today is
there for hundreds of thousands of Iraqi
Christians lives thanks be to God have
been spared have been helped because why
I was taught to dedicate my life to
service because my mom saw the goodness
of the American so if you help today
if you help Berta today if you help
Kamala today you're not just helping
that individual I promise you my friends
I promise you you are changing the
entire generation and that's what the
Lord I believe accept expects from us
I think humanity expects that of us and
these persecuted people their eyes are
on you a lot of people say America is
sending money sending money yes it's
starting to do so finally thanks to vice
president pence but it's coming slowly
and as we sit here it's early in the
morning there the suffering is very real
thank you Thank You Matthew
very grateful to you and Hillsdale for
holding this forum and for inviting me
and it's a great honor for me to join
these women have given their own
personal testimony
the United States is extremely unique in
the world for its value on religious
freedom are in the 17th century we all
just celebrated Thanksgiving thought
about the pilgrims 17th century they
came for religious freedom and many have
come since then legions Giuliana's
family I know some of the people here
also escaped for religious persecution
and their homelands and their families
their forefathers did in the 18th
century as Matthew said we adopted the
First Amendment and the first Clause of
this First Amendment is so important its
wording is unique Congress shall make no
law respecting an establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof this is completely
different from the approach taken by
many many other countries including in
the West they talk about ensuring
religious freedom the problem with that
formulation is that immediately sets off
a discussion about what is we
religion what is a religious group that
leads to registration and then that
leads to regulation and eventually
suppression sometimes very quickly so
you see in France today people time
being tied up in knots on whether to ban
Berkey knees in Canada the the Supreme
Court this summer just validated
stripping the accreditation of a
Christian law school because they were
Christian so the United States is unique
as Juliana said the people of the world
the persecuted the world really do look
at the United States for for help in the
20th century in fact twenty years ago
this fall in 1998 Congress and the
United States adopted the International
Religious Freedom Act and this act
institutionalizes us protection or
defense of those who are persecuted and
institutionalizes it within our foreign
policy apparatus there is an ambassador
at large in the State Department
ambassador-at-large for religious
freedom it's sam Brownback former
governor of Kansas former senator before
that and he is now our ambassador goes
around the world observing trials of
persecuted people like pastor Bronson
and Turkey or going to visit the
refugees and the row hanga camps going
to Iraq going to the camps they're
speaking about this and then they
produce an annual report which is still
the gold standard for really finding out
about cataloging documenting the
persecution around the world country by
country in every country of the world
also establishing this act the u.s.
Commission on International Religious
Freedom of which I was a commissioner
for 12 years and that Commission makes
recommendations often they're ignored
but by the State Department by the
administration but there's someone again
visit
in foreign countries talking about
documenting thinking about these issues
it's very very important
the it allows the United States to make
policy on the religious persecuted on
their behalf and Juliana was about
Rachel and Juliana were speaking about
Iraq and the persecution of Christians
and yetis these are two major non Muslim
groups that Isis targeted in northern
Iraq with the Christians there was no
church left open no priests operating
and no intact Christian community after
Isis took control four years ago about
7,000 Jews were killed 6,000 were
enslaved 3,000 remain and slit and
sexual slavery from the Yazidi community
which is a non Christian religion
the Christians also were targeted with
sexual enslavement there were scores of
women taken some of them have been freed
since then some haven't there have been
stories of women who saw their husbands
crucified to the front door of their
homes they're told by Isis to die like
Jesus Minh everything they had the other
this was called a genocide after a
enormous campaign by all of us Juliana
and me and others in this town were
campaigned very hard to get this
officially designated as a genocide by
the US government which we did in 2016
Isis came in 14 so this was two years
later and the reason why we did this was
we wanted to press for policies to help
these people because the other half of
this genocide was not only that Isis
came in and destroyed these communities
pushed them out they ran for their lives
and destroyed their villages town
homes businesses but the international
aid community including the United
States had a policy of not helping them
so that yes there's not a single camp
refugee camp in the Middle East for
Christians not a single one to this day
all the US aid went through the UM we
had two billion dollars of aid just for
Iraqis not to the government but for
Iraqis affected by Isis since 2014 all
of that money went through the UN the UN
did not Juliana describes some of it
with the refugees outside the borders of
Iraq but it also held within Iraq where
most of them were about 100 200,000
Christians about 500,000 use at ease
they did not the aid was almost used as
a counterterrorism tool that they the
refrain that we heard was well we have
to help the Muslims first because if we
don't there would be Isis 201 that Isis
would reform and therefore there was
nothing ever left over for the
Christians and the is it ease and they
churches filled in and a lot of the
large age aid agencies the very big ones
who are private swam like pilot fish
along with the UN and gave to the same
populations of the majority and ignored
the Christians yes we brought this to
the attention of the Trump
administration and in October last year
vice president pence promised that we
went to start giving aid directly to
these targeted religious minorities the
Christians and the cities of Nineveh in
Iraq but nothing happened no changes
were made there was no implementation of
this articulated policy so we had to put
the campaign on again gear it up again
put pressure prove go on TV
the pictures right the op-eds yet the
petitions rolling and finally after an
interagency coordinator was appointed in
September and sent to Iraq the money has
started to flow to these communities so
I'm happy to say that this is a success
that has come out of our system and out
of our policies it may be too late I
understand that there are privately the
patriarchs in Iraq say that there are no
more than a hundred thousand Christians
left in 2003 there was 1.4 million
Christians in Iraq so it may not be
enough it may be too little too late but
I think that there will be some who are
determined to stay and have nowhere else
to go who can who can really get back on
their feet with this help again the UN
has not changed its policy the u.s. has
and is made of is making a difference
now and I saw the list of projects and
towns and Julianna you'll be happy to
know that there is documentation now on
this we just got it two weeks ago and so
I'm optimistic about that but there are
the largest population of Christians
left in the Middle East is in Egypt I
just returned from there last month and
you may have seen that the there was a
pilgrim bus attacked and cops were
murdered on their way to a monastery
site
just last month this is the second time
this has been hit in the last year this
particular pilgrimage site and there are
two persecutors in Egypt there's Isis
and you all probably remember that
iconic scene of the cops the 21 cops in
orange jumpsuits on a beach with Isis
beheading them they were Coptic
Christians cop means Egypt in ancient
Greek they're the original Christians of
indigenous to Egypt
they traced their faith to st. mark the
Apostle they in fact their cathedral is
called st. Mark's and I went there and
Rachel I can tell you how powerful
photographs are and I'm so thankful for
your project I was very moved when I
went to st. Mark's and the church there
had the photographs of a couple dozen
women and girls who had been blown up in
that church a year ago and actually it
was two years ago now and it was just so
jarring to see these modern faces these
photographs of modern faces with the
crown martyrdom that the church had
placed on each of their heads row after
row so they were martyred in December
2016 when that church was bombed so
that's one source of the persecution in
Egypt it seems like president Sisi is
trying to do something about that trying
to protect them there was a lot of
security around the Cathedral st. Mark's
when I was there last month there he
does military strikes against Isis
pockets whenever there is one of these
attacks there is also another source of
persecution in Egypt and that is the
radicalization radicalized villagers the
neighbors of the Christians and they
will attack churches 500 churches have
been attacked in the last five years in
Egypt and there is no justice served in
those cases even though everybody knows
who did it
there are people killed and no one is
punished
there is no reparation there is no
protection for these villagers there we
have very good relations with Egypt the
US needs to be speaking out and really
pressing president Sisi to do more you
do you want me to stop now I want a
break because I could go on about Saudi
Arabia I mean there's all sorts of
there's no end but I do want to just say
that week we can do a lot speaking up
does a lot using our leverage of a
of trade opportunities all of this is
defense all of this are gives us a
tremendous amount of leverage if we if
we prioritize this thank you
[Applause]
so I'd like to thank you for the work
that you're doing when I was deployed to
Iraq my interpreter was an Assyrian
Christian and we had to work very hard
to get her here and then find her family
to try and get them here and as you know
that struggle is real
what disgusted me the most going through
that process was seeing how Christians
are actively prioritized last in those
refugee camps for aid so I was wondering
if you could just expand more on how aid
is distributed in those camps and how
that kind of ends up happening because
it's the struggle is real thank you for
your service thank you and thank you for
speaking up on that because you make it
even more real than I can
so inside Iraq the age when it does get
when it was getting to them so so let me
just describe what a camp look like when
Isis attacked people escaped on foot if
they could drive they drove then they
were in churches in court in church
courtyards on church pews in schools and
dormitories on the streets in the parks
the next day and it was and then winter
came along and winter in the northern
part of Iraq is cold and then they were
placed in on winterized tents and there
were 17 years leading kids there froze
to death in 2014 winter of 2014-2015
then they were moved into these shipping
containers that were that had in the
center of these camps there were
probably there was a large camp in Erbil
one is into Hook one is still open
operating in Baghdad so there were quite
a few camps there but the facilities the
bathroom facilities the shower
facilities were in the center of these
camps so the dignity was stripped away
from these people when when Aid was
getting to them there was very little
for food very little for hygiene
products there for diseases were running
rampant among them so that's within Iraq
outside Iraq there are no camps for as
you mentioned for Christians they're
living in slums and awful conditions in
Turkey UNHCR is a little bit better
actually my organization is launching a
massive campaign and Lisa in December
starting December 1 to help the 25,000
Christians there with some aid some
relief so UNH the UN gives a little bit
of money they have a little bit of money
for medicine the government pays a
little bit but in Jordan they don't get
anything at all in fact if I may not be
politically correct and tell you that
there are aid workers on the ground in
Jordan that are Muslim and Christian
that persecute and harass people
according to their denomination so if a
Catholic a Chaldean sees an Assyrian
person coming from the syriac church or
they assyrian church of the east they
say you're not a Chaldean we're not
going to give you anything go or the
Syriac says well you're a Chaldean
Catholic Vatican gives you a lot of
money go seek it from the Chaldeans okay
so that level of abuse also goes on and
there is no oversight we've been talking
to a lot of these big organizations
giving them information because I'm in
the Middle East often and I'm bringing
this report to them so yes if it does
get to them it's very little now with
what you were saying Aid has started to
slowly come in to northern part of Iraq
but still we have a long way to go the
the age I was talking about is actually
its infrastructure or yeah it's for
reconstruction to get people out of the
camps back into their villages now that
Isis is defeated put them back in their
places are in rubble but to help them
build their houses get the water going
turn on the electricity that kind of
thing but not for food not for hygiene
products that still is on a shoulder of
smaller organizations like mine and
others are are their private
philanthropic organizations or Christian
organizations who are operative in in
the
East and a [ __ ] oh how effective are
they what CN AWA is one of the
organizations that I think of kane' WA I
would say kanuha Catholics often near
associations they do a really good job
I've seen their work myself there are
many other organizations that raise a
great deal of money that really does not
manifest itself as it should if you can
read between lines if an organization
has raised 13 14 15 million dollars when
you go to Iraq when you speak with the
individuals we go to places that others
don't get to and they say there's no
presence of this agency here really
truly I mean that yeah well they're the
Knights of Columbus have raised a lot of
money and helped support these people
get them out of the camps into
apartments in in exile even though they
weren't back in their religious yet
they've also helped build houses aid to
the church in need is another
organization based in Europe they are by
the way lighting up tonight in red the
National Shrine of the Immaculate
Conception up on Michigan Avenue tonight
in honor of the martyrs and this started
in Europe with the I think it was the
House of Lords was lit in red last year
the Trevi Fountain in Rome the st.
Mark's Cathedral in Venice and this is
the first time the United States it was
happening so that's happening tonight
and you might want a drive pass there
Red's not the color of politics or
communism it's as far as I know the
largest Christian community today
nemesis is Syria here's the war in Syria
is the what larger larger Christian
community remaining today is in Syria
well no it's it's Egypt Egypt is sorry I
mean out of Egypt sorry yeah I mean out
of Egypt but my question is I mean was
the president yeah I'm sorry I just came
from BBC no no in Syria Assad Assad was
the guy who kept the ethnic balance and
the ethnic peace for very good Richard
good reason both in Syria and in Iraq a
minority person was the dictator and
that's why they had the Herot interest
to keep the religious and that in
balance if you remember the foreign
ministry of Iraq was a Christian I
forgot his name
Aziz these were secular governments they
were exactly but at that time we
portrayed him as you know the devil
incarnate and we shaked it and we you
know we created the Hulk out there and
so my question is today what are what
are you doing as a Christian
organization to influence the US policy
today towards the war in Syria so that
the Christian community there remains to
be protected well we didn't really the
u.s. didn't really get involved in the
Syrian war and that that conflict
started for other reasons it was the
Arab Spring if you would call started
ignited that war and we really didn't
have a partner in it and did not engage
to the extent that we did in Iraq I
think that in Iraq we the United States
made a terrible mistake to that that
unraveled and destroyed the communities
there I think that Syria is a much more
complex with a lot of foreign players
turkeys and they are fighting the Kurds
Russia is in there helping Assad and his
hands are not exactly clean in this
either he has used poison gas which is
the one time we did do strikes there but
it's it's I think very reductive and
simplistic to say that we upturned Syria
yeah I think I think it would I think
was a mistake for Secretary Clinton to
say that he must go I mean I think that
the Obama administration made a mistake
in saying that and it hasn't happened
and we've backed off of it waiting way
in the back
[Music]
aside whatever he may have been before
if he survives which it seems highly
likely now will have done so largely
with the backing of Hezbollah and Iran
how do you think that will affect his
behavior I can't possibly imagine it's
going to be for the better
Syria is probably one of our hardest
foreign policy challenges it's it's a
catastrophe
you know what is it half the country is
displaced half a million or more million
dead half it's a catastrophe in every
way humanitarian geopolitically there
are these foreign actors they are now
Iran as you point out to threat to our
interests it's a threat to Israel it's
there's no end in sight really you know
the Christian community is really in
Syria as you pointed out they are
terrified majority not all I can't just
they're terrified of us outgoing and
there are activists in the West who
fight against Assad they want him to be
removed and the people on the ground in
Syria they say what are you doing you're
sitting in the West you're fighting to
remove the man that is sort of
protecting us we don't want to know
their Iraq on our hands wholly replace
him with if you remove Assad so I think
the community inside Syria is terrified
of him going and then then that doesn't
even take account Europe which has also
you know deeply disturbed by the
migrations coming from Syria these are
mostly Sunnis who are trying to escape
Assad and so it's uh it it is
mushrooming situation oh my god when I
was observation you guys the experts on
this but it seems we have to keep in
mind one of the differences between the
Middle East and Europe broadly is that
you know why we have what we have today
here in America is because we we are the
result of a long development throughout
Europe coming from coming from the times
from from Aristotle through Thomas
Aquinas his confrontation with Aristotle
to through the Enlightenment that gave
us what we have today that's not
happened in large portions of the world
in number one and number two
there will always be despots and thugs
and you know dictators who take
advantage of that fact and that's the
problem you're talking about which is a
larger thing going going on yeah but the
I think the what's perplexing in which
is that these Christian civilizations
have survived not under great conditions
but they survived for two thousand years
right all that and the cradle of
Christianity and and Americans when I
talk to to audiences are very
passionately believe that Christians
belong in the Middle East and indeed
they've been you know it is for faith
reasons but also they've been the
moderators and the mediators the
moderniser is bringing hospitals and
modern education to this part of the
world first girls school was in Egypt
was a Coptic Orthodox school the first
you know university was it in one of the
great universities there is the American
University of Beirut where the
Presbyterian family that brought that so
somehow they survived until now and
in Egypt still fairly large numbers I
mean it's decreased over the centuries
because of these pressures because of
massacres because of genocides Armenian
Genocide but still they hung on and now
it's impossible the questions that come
here and say you know he's protecting us
your are usually calling back home to
check in every night because their
families are being held hostage so
there's that there's also the Democratic
Federation of northern Syria which is an
alliance a multi-faith group with whom
we have troops embedded right now it's
predominantly led by the Kurds and also
has Christians and Muslims and Arabs and
what-have-you so there are other options
anyway the actual question I wanted to
get out was is there any sense of
urgency within the administration that
you guys are aware of you pointed out
how pins a year after the fact of him
becoming insane we're gonna start giving
aid directly and everybody cheered it
still hadn't happened and it seems to me
there's a lot of folks a lot of
political apparatus in the State
Department bureaucracy that are stopping
what the Trump administration ostensibly
wants to accomplish and we're sitting
here it's basically the fault of to
admit to Republican administrations
including you know the bomb lenders
Obama administration as well that we're
watching Christianity extinguished in
the Middle East while we just kind of
sit around and we say we want to do
something but then you have the Trump
administration not cleaning house in the
State Department and not getting people
what they need I'm wondering if there's
a sense of urgency that is felt by
people you know in leadership positions
in the administration that recognize
this and have a sense of urgency about
fixing it yeah there was you know it
took four years after Isis for the u.s.
to reverse its policy of no aid to these
minorities took four years after Isis
that's a very long time to be living in
these shipping containers and you know
in churches and a lot left 100,000 or
more several hundred thousand I think
Christians left it from Iraq in that
period there after the vice president
realized the problem
it was less than a year after he was in
office
in October 17 it took another year for
them to figure it out and part of it and
I saw it up close was resistance from
within the bureaucracies of USAID and
the State Department yes and in
experience by the new appointees and it
took you know and I think a great model
going forward with our aid programs is
to do what they finally did ultimately
did in September which is put a
political point II who is dedicated and
on board with the policy in the program
on the ground overseeing and
troubleshooting the problems so that
when the electricity is all in place and
the money is spent and the electricity
still can't be switched on because
there's a minefield between you know the
substation and the village you pick up
the phone and call somebody to demine
the field and that's exactly what
happened in one case that he told me
about so this is a person who I know who
has been placed there is political point
II very dedicated very capable
determined to get things done and
empowered with direct responsibility to
the vice-president and to the
administrator mark green of USAID but it
took a full year for that for them to
figure it out and to to make that
appointment and I think we as Middle
Eastern as the ones they I'm not from
Iraq my ancestors are from Iraq but
sometimes just on Moss I say we Iraqi
Christians just to put that disclaimer
out there we are really hopeful with
this individual that that Nina is
talking about because he and others who
have been appointed to key positions
because these people have been our
friends for years they have served in
Iraq in different capacities and now
they're in key positions that understand
our plight we have come to Washington DC
since 2003 we have tried and you have
been such a strong voice 2005 2004 2006
I mean
Nina just put everything on the line and
she served so this population so well
with her whole heart but we weren't able
to really get what we wanted and I have
to tell you regardless if you're a
Republican or a Democrat but I tell you
we have friends in this administration
and if we don't obtain what we really
need under this administration if Trump
does not get reelected or if these
individuals or better individuals don't
come into this office in these key
positions you will see the end of the
Assyrians Chaldeans and see reacts from
Iraq which is a tragedy when Isis
attacked the Mosul Museum and the city
of Nome Road and they defaced the three
four thousand-year-old lamassu which is
the wing it ball that's my heritage
they're breaking my back I can survive
as a Christian in the East in the West
but it is my heritage of my history I
mean it I'm indigenous to Iraq and
that's what Isis was trying to do
it's the face and destroyed my monuments
there but we have hoped that this
administration people like Dena
understand our plight and if we don't
get what we want now and potentially if
he's re-elected if people re-elected in
this office next year like pence for
example we will not be able to survive
in Iraq it's a real tragedy look Inca
and Mayans are gone as an organized
entity as an organized community they've
been gone maybe they're living a
thousand or in pockets I'm an Assyrian
and I'm a Christian I am facing I'm
looking at death I'm staring death in
its tooth in its eyes I'm not being
dramatic when my kids when my grandkids
come to the west they raise their race
in the West they don't speak Aramaic
anymore
they're going to they're not our cuisine
is not our food is not going to continue
our dances our culture is a dying
culture I'm different than an Italian an
Italian can always go to Italy and Irish
can always go to Ireland take
grandkids and say this is where you come
from Nineveh my spiritual home by a
sister old home is in peril and this is
why every one of you can become an
educator of your friends and family
members to really step up and do
something about this it's not just a
mere Christian issue
it says civilization it's a heritage
issue as well how I add to that - that's
that's common we really have the
system's down the whole system this is a
third event I've showed my work at and
I've had countless people come up to me
all we're praying for this issue
oh we're thinking of you your books
great your photos are great and it's all
in words there's not been a single
action I've had a couple of Hillsdale
professors donate beyond that I've not
received a single a large donation nor
help for this project and that
cultivates down to what are we doing in
our society I teach high school in
Arizona I was able to present this
similar narrative to all of my high
schoolers and I an eighth grader
approached me on Thursday and tell me
that he and his little siblings are
setting up a lemonade stand raising
money for Berta that's the kind of
impact that we could make with things
like this and it needs to start earlier
because president can't Trump can talk
and talk and talk until we actually have
policy that's taking action that's great
but what are we all there's 300 million
of us in this country we all can do
something and I think it's time we all
start doing it thank you and I'd like to
thank all three of you especially for
your witness and for your work and and
what you've done and I encourage
everyone to get a copy of ter and hope
they're outside and continue to have our
conversation and ask other questions and
thank you all for coming
[Applause]